like we're stepping into the upside-down
with me reading an intro to an Anthony
Mason piece but I'll give it a shot here
the artist Leonardo drew started out
drawing superheroes over the past 30
years he's become a highly acclaimed
sculptor would work in the collections
of New York's Metropolitan Museum the
Museum of Contemporary Art in Los
Angeles and the Tate in London with two
notable new exhibit exhibitions this
year he caught the eye of our very own
Anthony Mason good morning Anthony good
morning Don I first came upon Leonardo
Drew's work while walking past a gallery
here in New York this past summer
through the door on the back wall I saw
this sprawling sculpture that seemed to
be leaping out at me when I went in to
take a closer look I discovered Drew's
story is as fascinating as his art how
long have you been with this gallery
this is my first exhibition with the
gallery
Leonardo Drew's exhibition at New York's
gallery lalangue last summer was
centered around one breathtaking piece
do you see this in your mind at some
point there's a lot of crazy stuff going
on in my head man so the sculpture
called simply number 215 looked like an
explosion frozen in space and time so
what is this actually made of these are
all store-bought materials I mean
started off with just plain birch
plywood
that's been treated with like color sand
so you've done this yourself yes it's
not a found stuff people always a
mistake in the work for like yeah found
objects these things are painstakingly
made in the studio I become the weather
yeah in order for the work to sort of
exist and you are the weather I love
that
and in his Brooklyn studio the 58 year
old artist is a force of nature this
piece just grows up out of your floor
basically it does yeah and it's even on
a turntable so it is the work he's made
here is now featured in the Harvey Milk
terminal at the San Francisco Airport
and at Madison Square Park in lower
Manhattan where he's created a city in
the park that was a playground for kids
this past summer so this is your book
from teenage years
mm-hmm drew grew up in the projects of
Bridgeport Connecticut
yeah his mother saw no future in it
until the child prodigy was given his
first show at 13 and at that point my
mother was like she laid off him because
you start having exhibitions and
bringing him money
and you live in the projects you're
doing all right so you were drawing
superhero superheroes I mean at that
time also Marvel Comics and DC Comics
came after me were you interested I was
because I thought that's what art was
but then in his high school library he
discovered a book on Modern Art and
Jackson Pollock just completely blew my
mind what did you see I saw unbridled
energy this push for aggressive push for
until unknown absolutely leapt off the
edge and you wanted to leap off the edge
I mean I've been leaping ever since Drew
suddenly stopped drawing entirely and
you just walked away from it in order to
get past this yeah this prettify surface
I need to challenge it so that meant
that it no more drawing find another way
to create he took a job at Christie's
Auction House working to save up enough
money to devote two years full-time to
his art and they gave us a bonus because
we sold the van Gogh
sunflowers yeah and they gave us all
Obamas and that kicked me over the top I
just like I was giddy with that freedom
came a creative explosion I was making
it but I wasn't thinking about showing
it what were you making it for
what a question I mean you look around I
mean you can see in a serious addiction
it's like crack so I am definitely the
crack addict of art how do you measure
success
it's an if I can get up and do this put
myself in an unknown and actually having
to dig myself out of that that is bliss
for me so there's never a moment where
I'm not asking what if in 1992 drew
began working with cotton that's him
pushing a bale 30 blocks to the studio
it's what kind of put you under me
exactly exactly for a black man to work
with that material obviously politically
I mean that's his charge material but
did it have that meaning to you it was
something I absolutely need to do but
once you did it and you did it well it
was time to move on
this is colored dirt that's colored sand
is that a way to force yourself to be
kind of uncomfortable yeah I don't like
the idea of being safe
he wants his work to have an emotional
charge what's in that emotional weight
some people say the dark yeah within
each and every one of us there's a
weight of our existence it's a
collective weight we all have it this as
human beings it's where our deepest and
most charged emotions lie drew travels
the world to China to Machu Picchu in
Peru to seek new inspiration for his
first outdoor sculpture in Madison
Square Park in the shadow of the Empire
State Building drew wanted to bring the
towering city down to the people and I
thought you know why not actually allow
the viewer to sort of be like Gulliver
and allow you to be the actually the
giant in this all through the summer his
city in the grass had thousands of
visitors did you kind of sneak into the
park and watch how people reacted that
was actually one of my biggest joys yeah
and just watching people you know enjoy
something that you made with your hands
yeah and they were literally like
becoming a part of it the sculptor in
fact came to life when they were on it
absolutely and it was just like this is
magic
the lawn is closed to traffic now but
his city is still up and we ignored
those signs these are put there so that
you could do exactly this to climb the
climb on it this is it you see the city
in the grass will be in Madison Square
Park through mid-december and will then
move on to the North Carolina Museum of
Art and the artist Leonardo drew will go
back to asking what if again yes he did
you can see Leonardo Drew's work next
month at the Hammer Museum in Los
Angeles and next spring if you happen to
be in Paris at Galerie lalangue in Paris
France we have just like what two weeks
to go check that out
swing by two weeks but I mean they'll be
more as you can see this man does not
stop working I'm a crack addict of art
look there's a reason I don't have a
family all night working his motivation
was so pure though all about the art he
didn't do it to make money he just did
it because he had to when someone who
would give up a drawing talent as as
significant as his was to throw himself
basically into the abyss to just feel
his way through it it's remarkable but
you see the result I think that's the
first time you've ever been called King
Kong though yeah
that is never that small city will never
look the same the way it does under the
lights of no yes no it's but it will be
it will move it'll be interesting and as
he points out every time a piece of his
moves it changes it development yeah
it's sort of adapt to the circumstances
and the people who say thank you